What's... every...
Oh ohh...
Hi guys! My name is Grace Helbig
and if you did not know, now you know
your life is different now!
I used to do a lot of videos
where I'd give you guys advice on things
so I thought let's
do.. it.. again..
That's... a little sample
of what I sound like in the bedroom.
And it's the time of year where many of you
are going back to school
so I went on my Facebook a while ago
and asked you guys for any questions that you needed
advice on in terms of going back to school.
And let's get into some...
"Grace-vice".
If any of you have a witty, interesting, clever,
fun idea for a name of whatever this segment could be
leave it in the comments down below!
*burps* Oh.
Okay, I am wide awake and tired at the same time.
That was my impression of a college student.
"Do you tell your roommates you have night terrors
in that you scream you're going to kill them in your sleep
or just let them think you wanna kill them?"
Leave them wanting more
information about your medical history
and exactly, psychologically, what's happening with you.
One of them might have a taser.
"Will people still think I'm cool if I can't afford
the nice binders and just get cheap plastic ones?"
Or will that destroy all the chances I have of making friends?"
Clearly you have a computer which...
... is infinitely cooler than binders, so...
"How do I get around the whole 'I have an open pack of gum
and other people have seen and now want some
but I don't want to share it
but also I don't want to look rude' dilemma?"
A taser.
"How to be openly gay in the high school of a small, rural, very Christian town?"
F**k 'em.
Have sex with all of...
...the close minded straight men.
That'll open up a dialogue.
"How to deal with being an older student around
all these goddamn kids?"
Wow.
Get a YouTube channel?
"I teach seventh and eighth grade, smelly bodies are a problem.
Please play my part in telling a kid
they need deodorant, or a shower."
I've thought about this, okay, here's my solution to your problem.
Day one of school,
hand out deodorant to every kid in every class.
Buy some travel size.
You can get bulk on Amazon. I've done it.
Hand them out to every student you have
and then just say "Y'all smelly! Use this."
Then you're not outing one specific student.
And hopefully it... you know ...it works.
Otherwise, like, I don't know...
... message them on Instagram?
"How do you deal with boring teachers?"
Ask them what their actual passion was
before they settled on teaching.
Just kidding! Teachers make the world go round.
"How do I sneak food into class without getting in trouble?"
Wow, this book is great!
*crunch*
No one will know.
"Advice for teachers on how to survive the first week?"
Take a s**t in the middle of the hallway
and just look at everyone and say
"F**k with me."
You'll set a tone.
"Do you have any clever ways to hide my open heart surgery scar?"
No, because you shouldn't cover that up!
Girl, you survived open heart surgery!
Wear that scar loud and proud.
I drunkenly tripped over a dog and fell down some stairs
and got stitches and have a scar above my eyebrow here
and I wear it...
... proudly.
"How am I going to pay back 150k in loans?"
Hand jobs.
I mean, jobs.
Getting a job comes in handy.
"Going back to college in a month, how to tell frat boys
you're not interested?"
A taser.
"As a teacher, how do I keep myself from going insane?"
Take a s**t in the middle of the hallway
the first week of scho-
"How do I not be an awkward human being?"
Honestly, I don't have an answer for this.
"What can I do to look like I give a s**t in class when I don't?"
I got you.
Fake glasses.
Paper.
Scissors.
Ta-da!
*snores*
No one will know!
"I am going back to school for the first time as a teacher.
How do I prove to my middle school students I'm cool?"
Take a s**-
"How to tell parents I dropped out of college? Lmao."
Send them this video.
Done and done.
"I'm graduating in December with my B.A.
I'm also turning 40 in November. Is that weird?"
No.
"I'm 5 foot 4 but I'm going into my final year.
How do I let the rest of school know I deserve
the same respect given to my taller classmates?"
A tase-
Well there you go!
There's some of my back to school advice.
Hopefully this was helpful.
Make sure you guys subscribe to this-
That's- this is the wrong gesture for subscribing.
Like this video by clicking the like button, and subscribe to this YouTube channel.
I make videos Monday, Wednesday and Friday.
Some time, put that bell notification on so you get notified
because it's not consistent...
I don't know.
"How do you handle anxiety when being overwhelmed by homework
while also having a social life?"
Just remind yourself that life gets, like, infinitely harder
after you graduate high school and/or college.
You have a safety net right now. You're being a pussy.
Life gets sucky.
So enjoy... it while you can. Subscribe!